all right thank you all for being here
I'll call the executive session of the
uh finance committee to order and note
that we have uh two Replacements
replacing Sharon nordgren we have
representative Miler and replacing
um representative Murray we have uh
representative luno
all right call the meeting to order for
the exec session on House Bill 1560 I'll
call on division two chair uh
representative Emer for report from that
division thank you Mr
Speaker chairman I mean I'm sorry Mr
chairman wrong
room this bill came to us uh we had a
work session on a Monday basically what
the bill does is it it takes the Surplus
which which is unspent and unallocated
allocated funds from the education trust
fund at the end of the year and moves it
into the general fund it does not it
does not eliminate the educational trust
fund it just says rather than keeping
cash unavailable to the state at the end
of the year any funds that are not spent
or allocated will move into the general
fund uh and Mr landrian has prepared an
ex the under current law what the
educational trust fund would look like
in the bayum so as you can see by the
end of the bayum without this there's
approximately $222 million that are
going to be sitting
unavailable to any other activity except
education in the state so what this
would do is we would never make it there
if the in fact it it it started in FY
2024 because at the end of FY 2024 182
million or whatever was unallocated or
spent would go into the general
fund so I I would look to uh
representative poii Mueller to make a
motion thank you I would like to make
the OTP motion for Bill
1560 is there and there is a second
second representative Earth
seconds further discussion
representative Heath thank you Mr chair
Mr chair we've heard a lot about
education um and we are very fortunate
in the last couple of years that we have
had money remaining in the educational
trust and we have been able to add any
number of areas that belong to
education um we have um episodic
treatment that this is the first bium
that we're going to see it already the
costs are anticipated at around 7
million we also are in the midst of um a
funding lawsuit um we know that we're
going to be running into some issues we
have a committee right now a special
committee appointed by the speaker
dealing with this I believe this bill
belongs there it does not belong at the
in right here um we are at a point where
we may need those dollars to to increase
the amount of funding that we're giving
to um our adequacy funding so I would
ask that we at this point in time defer
this bill to the special committee on
education funding that is actually going
to meet tomorrow this is not the time to
mess around with the education trust
what message are we sending to the
public by emptying out the education
trust what message does that send to
those individuals who are working hard
to bring more funding to education our
local property taxpayers are bearing 80%
of the burden of our schools we can talk
more about the cost behind special
education so I think at this time I
won't Bel labor this issue I've been
clear on where I am on this point but I
think at this point in time we would
be publicly we would look very foolish
by taking the step at this point in time
thank you very much Mr I would remind
all that were restoring this part of the
budget to where it was when it left this
committee and went to the other body
they're the ones that messed this up we
had it all balanced we gave education
everything they needed and much of it
was general fund as it has always been
the purpose of the of the education
trust fund was to fund adequacy that was
its beginning that was its most
prevalent use occasionally some other
monies were used but all the other
purposes for education
special ed catastrophic Aid tuition and
transportation building Aid have always
come from general fund there's never
been a problem whether there's money
specifically in the education trust fund
because we could always take it out of
the general fund but when we have a fund
like Highway fund Fish and Game monies
can't go out of them they can go in from
the general fund but they can't come out
and we would be stuck with the same
situation if we have education trust
fund with 200 million in it and we
suddenly find that we're 100 million
short on the litigation fund for the
senuna Youth Center what are we going to
do so we need to have this flexibility
we as the finance committee need to have
the flexibility to have more money in
the general fund for whatever is coming
ahead so that's why I put in this bill
because I think it's foolish to have
money in the education trust fund that's
tied up and can't be used even though
everything has been covered that was
requested for Education any further any
further representative hacken Phillips
thank you Mr chair um yes I'm going to
join my colleague U representative Heath
in calling for the built instead of
being exec here today um for the aop
pass but to be sent to the subcommittee
of education and that's for three
reasons the first is that this past
election cycle I canvased over a
thousand doors in my district and the
number one priority issue of my
constituents was to f fund public
education it was not in fact to drain
the education trust fund I think that
there's probably very few Granite
Staters who understand the intricacies
of what the trust fund does and this is
not something they're asking for so I
think we have to recognize we're not
reflecting the will of the Granite
Staters right now by entertaining this
motion second the process of our
committee receiving the
bill Monday
being designated to our subcommittee on
Monday afternoon and then the work
session that happened Monday afternoon
uh led us to today four days later I
think we can all acknowledge that four
days is a bit of a rush and that there
has been a lack of robust discussion
about the intricacies of what this would
actually mean for our state also there
was a concern that the AG did not weigh
in on the r decision and that there were
many members of subdivision division 2
who had questions about the
interpretation of that order and Our
obligation as division 2 members to
fulfill
that uh as well as also having several
members not being present that day and
while it is true that the committee
recommendation vote would probably have
led to this moment anyway I think it's
worth acknowledging that the people who
are most invested and knowledgeable
about the situation were not included in
the
discussion third I think that this is
probably not a prudent move given the
several unknowns that representative
Heath just spoke about but I'd also like
to talk about um a history that was
discussed in subcommittee of the general
fund not being adequate to fill the
education trust fund fully when there
have been instances that the education
trust fund needed additional funding so
we know that the statement that the
general fund can backfill whatever we
need is not entirely true we also know
that the continuing warrant articles
within the um um Appropriations list
lines 19 through 44 mean that we don't
know what the ending balances will be
for actual or estimated 24 and
25 um that these are just our estimates
our projections but we all know that
those warrants can be much larger than
estimated um given several unknowns
about you know for instance special
education requirements in our
communities finally i' just like to
remind the committee that this Rand
decision is really important and the
public is watching um they are aware of
what the court has ordered and they will
be watching The Way We react and I would
charge that the most prudent thing to do
would be to put this issue before the
subcomittee because they are tasked with
that exact question and how possibly can
we make a reasonable prudent decision
about how much money we can spend in
public education if we drain the trust
fund before we know the answer to that
question thank you Mr chair your
statements is
inaccurate any money in the general fund
can be used for
Education representative proii M you Mr
chair I just want to address one U I
just want to clarify something here that
the language of the bill does not say we
are transferring 222 million and
120,000 to the general fund it says
we're going to transfer Surplus I agree
that there are contingencies that may
happen happen that would require us to
change the funding for the education
absolutely true but any of those things
can be addressed from the trust fund and
that will reduce any surplus that we may
have this is why the language says
Surplus and doesn't specify an amount
specifying an amount would be imprudent
saying just Surplus is sound policy and
as I said I just wanted to clarify that
thank you representative Stringham yeah
thank you um I I think any attempt to
divert funds away from the New Hampshire
education trust fund is going to send a
damaging message that our constituents
will hear about our commitment to
education to do so at this time when the
courts have determined that we're both
underfunding education and doing so in a
way that is harming essential
communities particularly low property
tax towns will be heard our Educators
work tirelessly to provide the best
possible learning environment for our
students and we owe it to them in our
future generations to protect the
Integrity of the New Hampshire education
trust fund and this is going to be seen
as an attack on education even even if
we can move money around when we need it
it's going to be perceived that way I
don't think it's the right time to do
this and um I'd recommend voting against
it against a faulty perception let me
ask this question how many saw that
property taxes go down in 2023 over 2022
anybody
isn't that interesting we gave a 100
million from swept we gave 26 million in
the retirement contribution 126 million
went to all the towns and cities to
reduce the property taxes how much did
it reduce
them so don't get carried away with
exaggerating things about what the
public even knows about the education
trust fund all they know is we fully
funded education there's more money
available if need be representative Emme
thank you Mr chairman I I want to dispel
this the this comment about education
funding for adequacy one of the points
that was made I'm on that subcommittee
and one of the points that was made is
we cannot use
Surplus to satisfy adequacy adequacy has
to come out of funding in the period not
from past periods so Surplus like this
cannot be used to fund adequacy
representative Maguire thank you Mr
chairman so we all know that the
education trust fund is a polite fiction
when we budget we budget the education
trust fund and the general fund as a
single unit when we look at the Surplus
statement for example they're always
combined right and so already there's
the opposite of this bill in the sense
that if the education trust fund was
ever low it would get filled to the
right amount to the amount needed the
amount budgeted from the general fund
this is the complimentary piece right
that really makes them one unit the
reason that the education trust fund has
extra funds at this time is simply
because the amount put into it is a
certain fraction of BPT and a certain
fraction of bet and a certain fraction
of all the other taxes you see listed
here and there's nothing magical about
those
percentages right I mean if the
percentage let's say I don't even know
what the percentages but let's say it
was 30% of the BPT and this year the BPT
happens to be a lot bigger than
necessary for
Education um it's foolish to to force
that 30% to be some kind of a magic
number that can't be changed right we
have a lot of um requirements for
Medicaid and provider payments and on
and on and on so we balance when we when
we create a budget we balance one
expense against another we've decided
already for this bani how much education
should get and how much these other
things should get we're we're we're
collect ing new bills and new spending
requests and having the money in the
general fund is the most flexible place
to put
it thank you those percentages when we
left the budget we took 22% of the
business taxes into the education trust
fund to cover
adequacy the proposal that came to us
from the governor used
35% we sent it on to the Senate at the
22% they made it
44% twice what we put into would even
though we knew that would result in a
surplus that's what it did so it tied up
money that could be used anywhere else
in the budget including education it was
a bad decision which I'm trying to
overcome with this Bill thank you
anything
further representative
huitt usually I talk so loud nobody
anyway um we've been talking about uh
education in terms of uh all the
different things that go into the uh
funding of education and everything else
that ISO uh appropriated in in it's in
its general
milu what I've what I've observed since
since the whole debate started several
years ago uh is discussions about
schools and about
kids uh and not about how much should go
into this fund or that fund of the next
Fund in that connection I this is
completely uh unexpected uh I'd like to
read you a short letter that I received
this morning at 10:16
a.m. I believe you sit on the finance
committee HB 1560 came before your
committee on January 29th I believe the
bill wants to take money from the
educational trust fund and put it into
the general fund I hope you oppose this
with every ounce of your of your being
the ETF is supposed to be used to fund
public education and we all know that
the state is short changing public
education the recent November Supreme
Court ruling stated it should be double
what it is currently
funding what what this points out is not
necessarily the facts that the letter
wrer has put out but it's also relating
the fact what people have been talking
about all this time the problems that
have been discussed anytime you mention
the educational trust fund or any of
that stuff is education kids providing a
a good solid education to all of our
children and we hear debates that all
the time we hear some once in a while in
this committee about how we're not doing
enough or we're not doing it wrong right
or people have done something horrible
so I don't think that it's a good idea
to just out of a clear blue sky and
believe me I'm sorry I wasn't here on
Monday um but out of a clear blue sky uh
the U legislature steps up and all of a
sudden decides that well maybe we ought
to take the money out of there and start
spreading it around other places where
we think we need
it uh I haven't heard anybody say that
there's anything that we need that is so
important that we ought to tell the
public well we can't keep the all the
money in the education trust fund
because we don't know what is going to
happen at the end of this FAL year and
so I would not be in favor of taking any
action that would affect the education
trust fund at this time there's a lot of
misinformation going around I was with
the education trust from from its
Inception and there were many years when
we Del deliberately
underfunded what we even thought was
adequacy because we wanted to make it up
with money from other sources especially
the general fund because what we found
out was if we sent money to the if we
deliberately assigned money to the
Department of Ed that wasn't needed they
spent it
anyway and that was what we feared there
was one time we we got done we put all
the money that we thought we needed into
the into education
and then the estimate for the lottery
came in 4,000 more 4 million more than
we thought it would be and we said what
do we do now and we said to the
education department anyway we can get
this money back no no we'll spend
it that's was the reply we got so ever
after that we said all right we'll
figure out how much they need we'll make
it a little less because we know they'll
spend everything we send them and by the
way we spend more than $45 other states
and do we are we at the top of the 45
other states no we're not doing that
well for all the money we're spending
we're spending
$20,000 per public school student while
when we have someone in a charter school
we spend nine and they still get a good
education if they go to education
Freedom account they get five million
5,000 each and they still are happier
there than in this education at $20,000
per student so it's not being
competitive
it's not providing what it should it
just spends a lot of money without us
seeing the effect and I think somebody
has probably the teachers union has
spread a lot of misinformation that if
we take money out of the education trust
fund that is not needed in the education
department then we're being evil that is
such a misrepresentation and such
baloney that's been pulled out by the
teachers union and others I'm really
distressed by that we are here to make
sense out of the whole budget and to
manage the finances of the state and by
saying oh we got to leave money in the
education trust fund even though we have
not purposed it anywhere is a big
misinformation because I know one thing
that might go well over what we thought
it would be we put a 100 million into
the um the challenges on the Sonona
Youth Center the last time we met in in
fiscal it seems like they're
overspending that by a lot more that's
something that's already been approved
so that's kind of an open thing there's
nothing here in education that's open at
this time but that's open I know we're
going to be in asking for more money
there and I don't want everything tied
up where we could use another few
million out of Education trust funds
that are going that if we put them in
the general fund we can cover that
that's open it's there it's a commitment
all the commitments and education have
been funded so all these other arguments
are spurious in my
mind question representative L new thank
you very much Mr chair um to my
understanding the only blank check out
of the education trust fund is for the
education Freedom account voucher
program the um adequacy payments are
actually defined by Statute so they're
not the Department of Education is not
able to expend that money willy-nilly um
it's defined in statute the only amount
that's a blank check is for
vouchers thank you thank
you represent Edwards um thank you Mr
chairman I I'm I'm just going to explain
to anyone who who wants to listen to me
U why I'm going to vote to OTP this uh
one it looks to me by based on the
spreadsheet that the monies for
Education have been appropriated and
nobody's talking about reducing the
amount of money that's been appropriated
based on what's on the spreadsheet so so
the money is there it's fine uh then the
second thing is the the
million to me the way I look at that is
this is an
administrative reservation of
funds uh because you administratively
reserve funds that's a different thing
than actually trying to appropriate
money to spend on a program and so where
that money sits in its administrative
reservation is really not the relevant
issue the issue is which programs do you
care to fund and and so so I I I'm I'm
not hung up on the administrative
reservation piece of this the third
thing is that the Appropriations are
programs that have been
funded and um and that is completely
distinct
from the source of money that may be
coming in to say 22% of BP 18% of BPT
you know whatever the percent of a
revenue number is that's that that's
that's when you're looking at Revenue it
has nothing to do with the programs that
you want to invest in so um so I I I
think we really need to look more at
programs than we are uh the the the
source of money and um I I I know I sit
in healthc care and not in education but
I would love it a lot I would feel a lot
better about spending money if I heard
about programs that were intended to
improve the quality of
education education in New Hampshire is
not doing all that great from what I can
tell from the scores and so if we
invested in programs that would make
kids smarter I I would I would be up for
that conversation
um and then um I would say you know we
don't know what the future is but I I I
could see that we need some flexibility
the nation is being invaded uh States
all over the country are getting hit
with enormous unanticipated bills and so
far I haven't heard of New Hampshire
having that happen to them but I don't
know what what makes us exceptional um
the illegal invasion is coming it's
going to cost us money we better have
some money available so I'm going to I'm
going to vote for this uh primarily
because I I don't see the connection
between an administrator reservation of
money and the intelligent application of
money to on on actual academic
programs any further discussion be aware
that we've been cautioned not to go late
because we're holding up the staff they
don't want to pay overtime
representative Petri thank you Mr
chairman uh uh one of the things that
hasn't been mentioned is uh about 10
years ago we had about
221,000 kids in public schools we we now
have about 155,000 so this extra money
that's coming in is being just it just
sits there and not helping the kids
because adequacy is set in statute like
we've heard so I'm going to be voting
yes on uh this motion representative bu
thank you Mr chairman I just had a
question about how how do we address all
these incumbrances against the education
trust fund in in RSA
19839 there's a whole page full of
incumbrances including adequacy grants
in and also uh adequacy grants to the
charted schools charted Public Schools
uh at um grants to kindergartens and
every one of them has the same language
in it if required expenditures exceed
amounts appropriated then the
commissioner is is is authorized
to um request request additional funding
from the from the
um the the fiscal committee and and that
funding shall be a charge to the F
education trust
fund we've funded all those things we
put it in the budget I don't remember
them anybody ever coming to the fiscal
committee to ask for more money for
Education because they were shorted and
I've been on fiscal committee for 12
years so if it's necessary it will come
to
us and we will we will fund it but I've
never seen a request come through
education in 12
years Mr landrian any comment on on what
he said okay any further discussion like
to get to the roll call because of time
there's no further discussion the clerk
will call the role the motion is ought
to pass on House Bill
1560 1560
1560 thank you Mr chairman
representative Earth
yes representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative Emer yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean yes representative
hle yes representative Sweeny yes
representative camell
yes representative papich Muller yes
Representative
walner
no representative Miler no
Representative leean no Representative
buo
no Representative uitt no representative
Heath no Representative
luno
no Representative vble no representative
torski no representative hecken Phillips
no representative Stringham
no representative grassy
no M representative Wier
yes Mr chairman the vote is 13- 12 in
favor of the motion all
right is there going to be a Minority
Report it right
now no no you can't leave the
room that's the order of the speaker all
right I will and I believe represent
emmer or representative papichi has the
majority report ready okay uh I have to
R those so Heath is
responsible The Minority
Report motion
thank you all we are
adjourned